flipping houses is our passion Tareq and  Christina el Moussa are the hugely  popular stars of the HGTV remodeling  show flipper flock but now after seven  years of marriage the couple is calling  it quits we're constantly on the move  this is what we do but family always  comes first HGTV tells ET the show will  go on quote when it comes to matters  related to their own family we respect  their privacy and honor any decision  that works best for them and their  children HGTV is currently airing  episodes of flip or flop and the series  will continue production as scheduled  the split announcement comes after a  scary incident between the pair went  public EG obtained the police report  today which reveals officers were called  to their california home in May after  getting a call about a possibly suicidal  male with a gun Tarek and Christina  called the incident quote unenforced  anding and say that they are committed  to co-parent teens their two kids  you